bonjour et bienvenue sur les fréquences
de l'antenne radio et sur les écrans web
de martinique la première pour une série
de courts entretiens avec les candidats
et candidates des second tour des
élections municipales des interviews
d'une durée de 5 minutes à peu près qui
vous seront diffusés quotidiennement en
radio du lundi au vendredi à la suite
immédiate du journal de 7 heures et qui
pourront être retrouvés ensuite sur le
site youtube de martinique la première
donc sur le net jusqu'à l'avant-veille
du scrutin fixé je vous le rappelle le
28 prochain alors nous commençons cette
série avec jean françois bonhomme
puisque nous avons choisi de faire
intervenir les candidates et candidats
dans l'ordre alphabétique et donc avec
votre nom qui commence par la lettre b
monsieur il vous revient pour ainsi dire
d'ouvrir le bal bonjour jean françois
bonhomme bonjour monsieur le journaliste
monsieur k oui merci de m'accueillir
merci de nous permettre de démarrer
cette émission mais si vous me permettez
je veux juste saluer nos compatriotes et
remercier surtout les pilotins de
m'avoir fait confiance et pour me donner
l'opportunité d'opérer un changement
politique a dit un pilote je veux aussi
remercier pendant la période de
confinement tous les agriculteurs du
nord du sud du centre qui m'ont donné
des produits à distribuer à la
population et me permettre d'être au
côté de piloter pour leur apporter
quelques vifs
merci encore une fois alors
rivière-pilote donc le taux de
participation pour le premier tour a été
de 39,12 % l'épidémie de de covin 19
évidemment est passée par là puisqu'on
rappelle qu'en 2014 pour le premier tour
des élections municipales le taux avait
été de 54 4% donc près de 20 points en
moins ce qu on voit bien qu
effectivement toute la l'électorat de
rivière-pilote ne s'est pas déplacé
alors jean-françois bonal dans ce
scrutin si spécial en raison de
l'épidémie qui le caractérise vous voilà
avec peut-être le meilleur résultat de
vos multiples campagnes électorales au
aux municipales à rivière-pilote vous
avez recueilli 1216 voix contre 1299 au
maire sortant donc vraiment c'est serré
vous vous lui faites une sérieuse
concurrence mais même jean françois
bonhomme rien n'est encore fait d'autant
plus que 60% de l'électorat ne s'est pas
exprimé selon seulement appréhendez-vous
ce second tour si vous me permettez
à défaut de couvrir 19 j'aurais gagné
l'élection je vais gagner cette élection
la rivière pilote et en absence de mer
depuis 2014 et je crois que nous nous
sommes trompés en confiant les
responsabilités dans cette ville à une
personne qui ne jouent pas la fonction
est d'ailleurs pendant la période du
confinement rivière pilote n'a pas eu de
meilleurs présent un mec qui sortira
dernières semaines je trouve que c'est
manquer de respect à la population n'a
pas eu de mère pendant leur confinement
voilà voilà alors on revient on se met
dans la perspective de ce second tour
les conditions dans lesquelles ils se
présentent une triangulaire vous agrée
tél auriez vous pu faire alliance avec
l'un des deux autres l'un des deux
autres candidats
évidemment jean françois busnel dans
votre esprit sans que ce soit à votre
détriment donc qu'est-ce qui a fait que
ça n'a pas pu se réaliser notamment que
vous n'ayez pas pu faire une alliance
avec monsieur meyer vous savez
l'admirent d'ailleurs j'étais candidat
en 2008
en 2001 2008 2014 à chaque fois je
disais aux gens faisant travaille
ensemble il ya des choses que vous savez
faire
il ya des choses que je sais faire mais
thonon ensemble et travaillons pour
faire avancer notre commune en 2020 j'ai
fait une proposition de rassemblement
j'ai rencontré tous les candidats pour
leur dire la même chose travaillons sans
malheureusement peut-être que les mois
sont tellement gros d'autres ont des
revanches à prendre d'autres ont des
caractères particuliers
tout le monde voulait être de l'est là
vous l'avez fait cette année les
candidats j'ai encore fait cette
proposition et j'étais derrière monsieur
biro j'avais donné mandat à geron pour
me rassembler avec lui crée et mes amis
étaient prêts à le soutenir mais là vous
avez approché monsieur veilleuse
oui on gérera tronquée tout le monde ce
que j'avais rencontrée au premier tour
et y compris là j'ai fait des
propositions
vous savez il ya des gens qui pensent
que vivaient leur appartient et qui
doivent être les seuls à diriger via
pilotes manquent à divers plats de pâtes
à tout moment - mensonge - 88 ou ça
qu'il est donc à travailler puis tout ça
qu'ils envient travail mon caddie bien
sûr fait découvrir et puis les fascistes
en une phrase parce que ça va ça va très
vite vraiment très vite jean françois
busnel que dites-vous aux électrices et
électeurs de rivière pilote en forme de
messages brefs mais essentielles
concernant votre vision du changement
qu'il faut selon vous a apporté à bien
les pilotes dans leur grande majorité
veulent du changement
je suis l'instrument de ce changement là
je suis la force du changement dans tous
les points de vue et ils n'ont qu'à se
rendre compte du dysfonctionnement
actuel de la ville des services de la
mairie
le ccs inopérant la population est isolé
et j'estime que c'est pas normal pour
une ville comme lisa pilotes il ya trop
de chantiers en instance nous avons trop
de pouvoir il faut un vrai changement
arriver pilotes et ce changement la caj
au pot river à pire vous êtes confiant
pour le 28 je fais confiance à la
population parce que je sais que les
gens de divers pilotes sont raisonnables
merci jean françois bonhomme c'est moi
qui vous remercie de m'avoir lee
[Musique]